Véronique je laisse avec nos nouvelles
recrues merci bien
ça va vérifier ça va bien là ça va bien
Véronique moi je suis super alors je
vais crever la petite tout de suite
parce que Mathieu est Véronique faites
votre petit bisou déjà
un petit bisou à Véronique parce que je
sais que tu étais en ordre
du patronathan
moi j'ai rien contre Mathieu
je n'ai jamais dit ça mais il a droit de
dire qu'il aime pas un tel et un tel en
fait j'ai effectivement un problème avec
toi parce que je trouve que vous connais
pas
forcément très brillant mais voilà c'est
mon premier il est brillant
il va y avoir une bonne ambiance de ce
côté là
Véronique sinon pas brillant
ça va moi j'adore
oui je le déteste pas je déteste
personne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la sienne et j'ai été invité c'était
quand même un truc pourri
[Rires]
et le sujet qu'il avait fait à charge
alors le sujet
c'est bon tu es complètement à charge et
complètement débile tout comme l'article
qui vient de citer qui n'a jamais existé
merci Véronique en tout cas d'être là et
à Benjamin qui est là Benjamin toi ça va
Véronique
[Applaudissements]
je suis fan de Véronique moi j'aime
beaucoup
je peux faire un petit bisou aussi
ça va être incroyable ça va demander du
coup hier tu te
prends
il t'a demandé les 500000 non non
[Rires]